As an example, let's take a look at Wikipedia.
As you can see, there is a lot on this page.
There's text and lots of different images of different sizes and
shapes, but let's take a look at the inner structure of the site.
I'm using Google Chrome as my browser,
which includes really great Developer tools.
And you should be sure to follow along with me.
In Google Chrome, if you select this three-line icon at the upper right of your
screen and select Tools > Developer Tools,
an additional panel will open at the bottom of the browser.
This shows you the structure of the page.
And this is a really important fact to know.
What you see here is not the actual code itself but
rather the structure of the page as the browser interprets it.
If you mouse over the lines or
elements in the structure, you'll notice that parts of the page get highlighted.
If you click on the triangle to the left of a line, it expands.
And you can keep going deeper and deeper into this tree-like structure.
There is also a separate panel on the right side, which is called Styles.
And this contains a different type of information.
Go ahead and explore the site on your own and as you're exploring see what
observations you can make about the Wikipedia page and structure.
And when you're done, which of the following statements did you find true?
Are all elements of the structure visible on the page?
Are all highlighted elements rectangular?
Or, if you go deep enough in the structure,
can you read the same text as you see on the page?